[Music]
yeah and then I did want to talk about
strafe more in depth because Michael hi
I'm his review went up he gave it eight
out of ten a great out of ten yes yes
and uh he liked a lot obviously but I
played it yesterday Rob you and I were
kind of playing it during our lunch
breaks yeah I play it for like hour and
half two hours yeah um I feel like I got
the gist of it pretty quickly
which is not to say the squeakiest
cherub sorry I'm not trying to go out to
you
what's the for people who aren't
familiar cause it's sort of like not
super on everybody's radar what's like
the elevator pitch
it's like styled after like early 90s PC
first-person shooters and it puts you in
these procedurally generated levels
where you might find some weapons that
are super helpful or just a standard
fare of weapons and you have to fight
these enemies as you explore the map and
look for sort of the exit each like
level has like a few components sort of
like a Super Mario World
you know we have like world one when one
one one two and three that kind of thing
it's also pretty difficult it's very
difficult yeah I saw from a lot of
review that went up they said that they
didn't finish it Michael was saying he
read a bunch reviews I don't think I
think but they're pretty honest about
they're saying it's just really hard we
still liked it I know like IGN I don't
think got the chance to finish it before
embargo any places Michael was like here
late like yeah how is this game but it
gets it like it's not about marathoning
because it takes so long it's just like
you know you get to like the end of the
game and you die you start back at the
beginning yeah yeah it's a roguelike so
you've got a you know kind of pick
yourself back up and try it again which
can be tough for some people myself
included yeah like for me I was like you
know as you should know you throw those
oh really oh I did that how do there a
couple times cos ammo was like getting
spares
oh my haven't seen that guy yet nearby
uh and that's things like everytime you
know as you progress you get hit with
you know some new enemy type and it was
the ones that were like on the ceilings
I would spit out like homing of events
that shoot oh sorry
waste you and then they have that asset
on the ground that's right so when you
kill them they spill acid everywhere
basically and that stuff takes them if
you step on it takes away a lot of
damage so in this game you are just
reliant on moving
I'd credibly fast and that is just one
of those things you get to tack on but
all right now I got changed my whole
play style
uh it's just yeah you're gonna dialogue
right that's a little buggy to like when
I was playing today I was noticing some
like pieces of models were like
stretching across the screen like an
environment like a guy that I killed
like there was a polygon that was like
uh but also like I picked up a rocket
launcher at one point and I found on the
ground then I was all right cool I don't
want to use that yet I want to save it
so I used my weapon wheel to go to a
different weapon I went back to the
rocket launcher and it was in the state
where when you run out of ammo you can
only just toss the weapon right you
can't melee with it I thought you could
melee team I throw it or melee I
couldn't get back to actually using I
hadn't actually used it I had I had ten
rounds day left for it and it was like
the dude I had I had different straight
for was Michael just comparing cuz this
is his video review right oh no this is
all strafe they'd apparently there's
this is that Wolfenstein no but this is
a like a moshing amage to a superhot
right here like generally a weapon that
lets you that recent time yeah he was
talking what easter eggs and what we
just saw was that like gameboy style
oh yeah yeah one thing Michael had
complained about and you raised this to
me as well Pete and I didn't think about
it until I played again and I agree is
the weapons don't have much have to him
I know it's a PC keyboard game or a
mouse and keyboard focus game although
it is on ps4 but the weapons I mean you
fire and it it's not much impact on the
enemies you get I mean
well [ __ ] that's the worst thing to
prove my point there's a lot of impact
there but I guess it's kind of blow Civ
right yes you're using a shotgun or a
machine gun it feels like using a
peashooter kind of yeah yeah because
there are a decent amount of weapons
more than I thought you know that those
three two from the beginning ones like
this more precise laser rifle if you're
kind of really good with a mouse which
I'm not and then there's a shotgun and
like a SMG that also its secondary fire
is a few grenades but yeah then you pick
up these power weapons do you find those
uh it showed it earlier it looked like
that little what was that thing from big
fortune tellers or zoos or knows ULA's
ghostbusters books or whatever his name
was you put the gun in and he like it
looks like a fortune-telling booth and
then you you
age and you you dance on the school
board with no I'm just talking about big
now uh yeah it upgrade your weapons and
you can like I saw you were using the
double-barrel shotgun after a while Rob
not that super hot one but the original
one that you upgraded yesterday yeah
that was that was neat I mean I just
found things a little too like vague or
ambiguous it's like hard to gauge like
what ammo types or or maybe even the
currency like I I didn't find it very
like heavy-handed on the tutorial aspect
we're like I couldn't like see something
on the ground and know exactly what it
was currency is especially like yeah al
to pinpoint so it's like I mean only
playing two hours I was like kind of or
hour an Apple just like trying to figure
out like all right what exactly am I
looking for or striving for oh sorry you
know yeah it but it again like this is
such a fast-paced game it's kind of hard
to soak in and like experiment when
you're going up to a currency booth and
like doors open more guys come in like
you it's it's tough to like get a grasp
it's also the trouble with when you're
sticking to like a classic aesthetic
because it can be harder to visually
indicate what something is when you are
trying to make it look old if that makes
sense right
like sometimes it could just be hard to
do some bugs
choo-choo-choo-choo JJJ Oh God gee God
you guys watched the movie trailer for
it
mmm from the what you're all still 96
shorts yes if you've seen the trailer
from God it was like a year or two ago
uh it's very much in the same vein I'm
just like you know VHS 80s retro but
like hardcore heavy gory about oh my god
there's this one where he stabs a FBI
agent with a skateboard into his stomach
and rips out his intestines sweet and
then like his friend jumps on his friend
jumps on the skateboard and takes off
there for pulling out feet and feet of
intestines like Nora Lee and that's the
same style of that actually transfers
into the game where it's like if you
guys did a tutorial at all do you see
that isn't that that doctor woman
telling you it was in the video review
as well um it's pretty funny and you see
that in the game right like you go
through like
I want to say it's like a area where
you're then able to put your scraps to
use and stuff like that and there's like
a series of signs it's like well they're
those gnarly like go for it like I don't
know it's it's got it the style of humor
that like an 80s skateboarder stoner
would have which is which is nice and I
it's kind of funny to read that stuff
yeah I might be like hobo a shotgun vibe
or turbo kid yeah I even specifically
that intestine thing yeah yeah right
what is he doing turbo kid I forgot
does he take an equity strangle is he
strangle someone yeah it's an exercise
bike in the knee they like they put a
like a hook in his stomach and grab his
intestines and then they let they're
interrogating him and then he gives them
the info they want and then they still
do it anyway hmm and it's such like you
were describing the noise it's just this
grinding noise well the word learn about
all of that
like just ridiculous violence is that as
this guy's intestines are being ripped
out he's like oh no like I would not
want to be alive for any of that but a
date leadership like always is like aa
movie where the the dudes got was it
Tropic Thunder I feel always like she's
like yeah back in yeah oh yeah I was
like if the fake war scene in the
Vietnam War scene
yeah that movies on Netflix now you
should watch it yeah what one thing I
really did want to say about strafe is
um like quake was one of the first games
I ever played um and like quake and do
more to the first games i remember
playing and so like this is a game that
like I want to play anyway because I
have that installed job but do you think
it has like it has enough going for it
for somebody who maybe doesn't have that
because that's that's what I from what
I've seen in play like that's not I
don't have a sense for that yet right I
think you guys have played more than I
have that was definitely my main draws
the classic shooter feel to it not
necessarily the rogue-like elements
because it is very much a roguelike it's
not no glite like you don't carry any
progression between right when you
restart I don't think I don't know if
every time I've died I didn't have much
progression but yeah uh it definitely
feels like I like it more because it's
paying homage to those yeah that's the
sense of everything but it's also kind
of it's a nice contrast what I've been
playing lately it's just very fast
the soundtrack itself I just the first
soundtrack I bought it's like seven
dollars if you like that kind of
hardcore out run kind of synth 8e stuff
I don't know how I'm describing it well
but you should check it out because it's
really good I've been listening to it
throughout the day now just talk about
hard driving tempo like that he's like a
heavy sense yeah it's really good fun
really good it's my toy tree the artist
I don't know if that's a it's a look at
my buns look at that artist up on
Spotify but yeah Michael hyams review is
up you can go read it at GameSpot it's
an 8 out of 10 if you want to read more
about it
[Music]